a convex combination of pure States and second conditioned on getting a particular measurement outcome the
state of X becomes the corresponding pure state from the convex combination so why is that
interesting well it means that for any way that we choose to think about the reduced state of X as a convex
combination of pure States there's some measurement of Y that effectively makes this way of thinking about the reduced state of x a
reality and what's remarkable is that this is possible even when the state f is chosen first and the convex
combination is chosen later as long as it's an expression of the reduced state of X there will be a
measurement of Y that works exactly like this so let's see how we can prove
this we start with two different expressions for the reduced of X which will give the name Row for
convenience next we introduce a new system Z whose classical states are the possible measurement outcomes or
equivalently the indices in our convex combination and now we can observe that the following two Quantum State vectors
gamma 0 and Gamma 1 which are both state vectors for the compound system XYZ are
both purifications of row and just to be clear when we're thinking about these vectors as being ifications of row we're
thinking about the systems Y and Z together as a single compound system that gets traced out to leave
Row the first Vector gamma 0er is essentially the same thing as the original pure State 5 except that we're
initializing the new system Z to the zero State it's clear that if we Trace out Y and Z we'll be left with row so gamma
0er is a purification of row the second Vector Gamma 1 is basically the vector we get by purifying
row based on the convex combination just like I described earlier in the lesson this time the system Y is
initialized and I'm assuming just for Simplicity that zero is a classical state of Y but you could substitute any
standard basis state or in fact any pure state of Y into this expression and it wouldn't make any difference in any case tracing out Y and
Z again leaves us with row so the bottom line is that these are both purifications of row and therefore by
the unitary equivalence of purifications there's a unitary operation U on the pair YZ that transforms gamma 0 into
Gamma 1 and that's all we need to come up with a description of a measurement that does what the theorem
says a simple way to describe it is with a circuit diagram like is shown here on the screen in words we start out with the
state F we introduce Z initialized to the zero State perform U and then measure the top system which is Z with a
standard basis measurement effectively what this does is to transform fi into Gamma One and
just by eyeballing the description of Gamma 1 we can see that this does what the theorem says which is that we get
each outcome a with probability PA and conditioned on getting a the system X is left in the state sa
a and just to be clear the measurement itself that the theorem implies the existence of is implemented by
everything in the dotted rectangle in the figure and if you want to know how the
measurement can be described as a collection of matrices here's an expression of them I won't explain this part and it's
not really important for the sake of the example but that is an expression of the measurement matrices in case you're
interested next we'll discuss Fidelity which is a measure of how similar two Quantum states are or alternatively how
much they overlap we'll start with the definition which might look a little bit mysterious at
first glance but we'll unravel it and by the end of the discussion I hope that I will have convinced you that it's
actually a much nicer function than it might seem at first glance and here's the
definition the Fidelity between two density matrices row and sigma is equal to the trace of the square root of the
square root of row * Sigma time the square root of row we'll talk about
it first let's just try to make sense of the definition itself we have three square roots and
they all refer to the square root of a positive semi-definite Matrix which as we discussed in the previous lesson is
the unique positive semi-definite Matrix that squares to give us whatever Matrix we're taking the square root of because
row is a density Matrix it must be positive semi-definite so we can take the root of it and if we think about theot of row *
Sigma theot of row for a moment we see that it's also positive semi-definite and in particular we can write it as
mger * M for M being theare root of Sigma time the sare root of row and therefore we can take the square
root of it in particular we can compute a spectral decomposition of the root of
row * Sigma * theun of row and then to take the square root we just need to take the square roots of the IG
values and leave the IG vectors alone and finally we take the trace of
this Matrix and because the trace equals the sum of the IG values we obtain the expression that we have right
here so that's probably something that you don't want to compute by hand in general and this explanation might not
offer very much insight into the Fidelity or why we care about it but hopefully it clarifies the technical
meaning of the formula by the way just as an aside sometimes people Define the Fidelity to
be the square of the function that I've defined right here and they refer to this function as the root
Fidelity you'll see it defined both ways which certainly has the potential to cause confusion but it usually doesn't
because people are generally pretty careful about making clear which definition they're using and you should
be sure to do the same thing to my eye there really isn't a right or a wrong definition I Define it
like this simply because I got used to doing it this way and I do find that it's a little bit more convenient I guess because I'd rather Square
something then take a square root later on when the need arises but of course you're free to make your own
choice but anyway let me get back to the Fidelity as it's defined here there are other equivalent ways to
define the Fidelity and it's actually a pretty remarkable function in that respect and it can actually be characterized in some pretty interesting
ways here's a pretty straightforward way to rewrite the definition in terms of the trace Norm which we saw toward the
end of the previous lesson I didn't go into too much detail about the trace norm and in particular I
didn't even Define it for non-h herian matrices but it does have a simple enough definition one way to define the trace Norm of an